okay every once in a while I like to
look at what the betting money has to
say about what's going to happen in
November of 2020 and there's something
interesting which is that if you pull
people and say who do you support in an
election you get one set of results and
that's the way typical polling is done
you can do the polls a different way
which is you can say regardless of who
you support who do you think will
ultimately win an election and you often
get different results and very often
they are quite accurate one way that
people show who they believe is going to
win is by betting money in prediction
markets which you can do online and in
the last 48 hours something very
interesting has happened the money now
has Bernie Sanders as the most likely to
be Democratic nominee again this is not
who supports Bernie it's what are people
betting on in terms of who will be the
Democratic nominee and it still has
Donald Trump's re-election as the most
likely single outcome in fact
significantly spiking as well over the
last little while so let me explain all
of this predict wise is a website that
aggregates the betting on different
betting websites oftentimes thinking in
bets is a good idea to clarify how
confident we are in our belief that
something will or won't happen so for me
to say Bernie's going to be the nominee
or he won't of course I can't have 100%
certainty that he will or that he won't
so sometimes when you think about it as
a bet you're assigning some level of
confidence so for example if I have 60
percent certainty that Bernie would be
the nominee I might be willing to bet a
hundred dollars to win a hundred and
sixty dollars on that bed right I'm
making up these numbers or if I'm not
super confident I might be willing to
risk $100 or only if I were to win 400
if I was right because my confidence is
lower so I've got to have more possibly
coming my way raising the expected value
of the bet the math doesn't really
matter except to say that a lot of
people are betting on these outcomes and
over the last six weeks the money
betting that Trump
we'll be the eventual winner of the
November 20 2011 has gone up quite a bit
and is now at 53 percent 53 percent of
all the money being bet says Trump gets
reelected the next most likely outcomes
are 14 percent believe Biden will be the
next president 14 percent believe Bernie
will be the next president much smaller
percentages for other candidates now for
the Democratic nomination over the last
few days the numbers have hugely spiked
for Bernie Sanders putting him in the
lead 31% of the betting believes Bernie
will be the nominee taking a lead over
28 percent who believe it will be Joe
Biden 11 percent say Bloomberg and 10
percent say Warren so as you can see
these numbers are not the polling
numbers Bloomberg at 11 percent is way
over representative / representative
represented relative to the 5 percent
that he's polling because again these
are prediction markets this is not who
do you support it's based on all factors
that you consider who do you think will
ultimately win so what has caused this
there's probably a number of factors
number one Bernie taking a lead last
week in the historically important Des
Moines Register poll of Iowa voters has
certainly helped him in the prediction
markets Bernie taking a lead in a number
of recent California polls California is
an important state for the primary many
delegates Bernie leading in two of the
last three polls there to some degree it
appears that the Bernie said a woman
can't win attack that Fiasco may have
failed and Bernie may not be as
vulnerable as some might think to such a
smear campaign and that may have helped
him in the prediction markets as well
although I'm sure there will be more
attack attempts in the coming months now
there's an important statistical reality
that we have to contend with here you
hear a lot of Bernie supporters say
Bernie's the only one who can beat Trump
many people say this about whoever they
support we have Bernie supporters who
say Bernie's the only one that can win I
have yang supporters who say Yang's the
only one that can win I have tulsi
supporters who say she's the only one
that can win not so much about Biden but
the idea is a lot of people say to me
the person ice
Court is the only one who can defeat
Donald Trump in the betting markets note
that as Bernie's nomination has become
more and more likely based on the
betting trump's reelection has also
become more and more likely in terms of
the betting so it may be different
people betting on each but we have to
contend with the reality that as more
and more people believe Bernie will be
the nominee more and more people believe
Trump will be re-elected President of
the United States given the historical
accuracy of the betting markets we may
not want to ignore this although of
course nothing is set in stone and
trying to defeat an incumbent like
Donald Trump is different than anything
that we've seen in American political
history so let me know what you think
about this and specifically here's the
question I want you to answer why have
the betting odds for a Trump reelection
increased in parallel with the betting
odds for a Bernie Democratic nomination
I want to hear from you we will follow
up about this on the David Pakman show
Instagram please make sure you're
following it at David Pakman show and
while you're there give me a follow I
posted some unhinged hate mail this
morning that I got I'm David Pakman on
Instagram